learn how to create a custom blog with
html and css in this full course from
julio codes
what is going on everybody
my name is julio and in today's lesson
you will build a responsive website from
scratch
before i give you an overview of the
project i wanted to thank
recodecam.org for lending me their
platform and allowing me to share my
knowledge with you today
now let's take a look at the project
that you will build
first let's go over the header the
header section holds the navigation and
all of its items
here we have the theme toggle button
this button will transition the color
scheme into the light theme
we will use javascript to store the
theme selection within local storage
this means that your theme selection
will remain active even if you close the
page or the browser
then we have the search button when
clicked a pop-up will be activated and
the search bar will show you have two
options for closing the pop-up you can
either click on the close icon or hit
the escape key on your keyboard
moving on we have a sign in and sign up
button these buttons do not lead
anywhere but if you wanted to build upon
this project you could create pages for
these buttons
also we have a cool hover effect on the
sign up button
for some of you this might look familiar
in fact the entire dark theme might look
familiar and this is because i use
codepen ios color scheme for inspiration
then we have the main section
this section will be a grid that is
split into two sides
here we will have nested grids as well
on the left we will utilize grid to
position the items in a way that will
allow us to create a really nice looking
layout
then on the right side we have a sidebar
if we come down here we have the quick
read section we will utilize a
javascript library called swiper to
create a responsive carousel
swiper has many functionalities however
we will only be taking a look at
responsive breakpoints and how to make
the arrows and pagination work
then we have the older post section
this section is composed of six cards
though you could show as many as you
wanted
towards the bottom you have the c-more
button and this button would allow you
to either show more posts or navigate to
a specific page
the next section is for the popular tags
this section is composed of six cards
ideally when clicking any of the cards
it would take you to a page where you
would see posts specifically for this
category
then we move down to the newsletter
section
here we have a call to action prompting
users to subscribe to the newsletter if
they wanted to
then the last section will be a modern
looking footer
i also wanted to show you the second
page the blog post page because aside
from the landing page it would only make
sense that we also build a blog post
page
to access this page let's go back up to
the first section
then we can click either of these three
main cards although the page for the
post is basic you have a lot of room
here for making this page more complex
if you wanted to
let's go ahead and take a look at the
responsive view
let's start with the navigation
then let's scroll down and take a look
at the rest of the layout and how it
changes and the adjust with the width of
the viewport
lastly i wanted to point out that i have
a youtube channel of my own
if you enjoy this type of content be
sure to give me a follow
without any further ado
let's begin
let's quickly go over the files that
you're going to be getting so if you go
to the link listed in the description of
this video you're going to be able to
download the completed files as well as
the starter files
i decided to include the completed files
just in case we run into issues this way
you can just compare the code
now i'll just close this and then go
inside of the starter files
so if you plan on following along make
sure that you pause the video grab the
assets and once you're ready let's begin
let's begin by going over what we have
here within the index.html
so this is just a basic html5 template
here we link to the favicon which is
this little icon that we have here
then down here we link to the remix
icons which is the icons that we are
going to be using
then we link to the swipe.js css file
and then we link to our own css
inside of the body here we just have
several comments for each individual
section
and then we do the same thing down here
instead of linking to the css we just
link to the javascript files
so the first thing that we are going to
do here is go inside of the header
actually let me open up this project
with live server first
just so that we can see the changes as
they happen
i'm also going to keep the completed
project here opened just so that we can
use it as a reference
so first let's tackle the header
and inside of the header we just have
the navigation and all of its items
so we're going to use the header element
then we will apply a class of header as
well as an id of header
the id i'm only going to be using it so
that i can select this element as well
as other elements through javascript you
can do this with the class and even the
tag name however i opted out to use the
ids instead for this purpose
inside of the header i'm going to use
the nav
element i'm going to apply the class of
navbar
as well as a class of container
the container class will limit how wide
a particular element is going to stretch
to
inside of the nav i'm going to have a
logo so i'll use an anchor tag
i will point this back to the index.html
and then inside of it i'm going to have
an h2 that will have the class of logo
and the name of the website
then i'm going to have a div with the
class of menu as well as the id of menu
inside of this div i'm going to have a
ul with a class of list
and then inside of it an li with the
class of list item
and then inside of the list item an
anchor tag with the class of list
link
so now that we have the base for the
list items all i have to do is just copy
this and paste it down below as many
times as we need
so we're just going to set up a few for
now and then we'll add the rest later
also the main reason why i'm wrapping
this list inside of this menu is because
it's going to make the reset when we
transition from mobile to larger screens
a lot simpler
so for the first one we also want to add
an additional class of current
since it will be highlighted
and this will be home
then we have categories
then we have
reviews
news
membership
contact
and then here we have the sign in
link and we need one more
for sign up
i also want to add an additional class
here
this class will be screen
lg
hidden
and i'm going to apply this class to the
sign up button as well
so the main reason is because these are
the links that will show up within the
mobile navigation that you see right
here so these are normal links
and then when we get to the larger
screens we hide them from here and then
we show the fancy ones instead
so let's go back here make this smaller
and i'm probably going to give myself
some more space so i'm going to close
this sidebar here by using ctrl b
just like so
now something else that i want to do is
i want to now exit this menu div
and underneath i'm going to add the rest
of the buttons that we have here
so to do so let's find the closing tag
for this menu div
and underneath we are going to have
another div this one will have the class
of list as well because i want to share
some of the styles without having to
override the existing styles for this
link
for this list i should say so that's why
i'm also going to give this the class of
list write
and in here we are just going to have a
lot of buttons
so we are going to start by using the
button element and we will apply the
class of btn
a class of place
items center
and then an id of theme toggle btn
and inside of here we will have two
icons so the first icon will have the
class
of array
sun
line
then i'm going to add a secondary class
just so that i can manipulate this
element by using the secondary class
so i'm going to call this sun
icon
then we are going to duplicate this down
below and we are going to edit it so for
this one we can say moon icon
and then we can change
sun to moon as well
and if we go back to the original
project here you'll see that the button
is now visible and we have the two icons
that we want
later on we are going to hide one of
these icons so that only one is visible
at a time
so now that we have the base for the
buttons what i'll do is go ahead and
copy this again let's just be a little
bit lazy here
and then i'm going to modify this
element to fit our need
and for this one we will have the search
icon
so this can remain the same the only
difference here is that we're going to
get rid of this id
so instead of this id we're going to use
search
icon just like so or we could even do
search icon btn it doesn't really matter
then in here we can go ahead and get rid
of one of the icons since we only need
one
and then we can go ahead and change the
class
so this one is going to be ri
search
line
just like so
and now we get the other button so we
need
one more here
and this button is going to
let me actually copy it again
then i'm going to paste it below here
and
here we're going to have to make some
changes as well
so for this particular button i'm also
going to add a class here of screen
lg hidden because i don't want to see
this particular button on larger screens
since the menu is going to be fully
visible
i'm also going to add a class here of
menu
toggle
icon
and then for the id we can just go ahead
and change this as well to menu
toggle
icon
we will also have two icons in here one
is going to be for the hamburger menu
and the other one is going to be for the
x
so here we can just go ahead and modify
the classes
this one for the hamburger menu we'll
have the class of arrive menu and then
3
line
and that's already going to show up
there
then we need an additional class
called open
menu
icon
then what we can do is copy this and
replace the one
below it and then make changes here so
we can change this one
to
close
and then we can get rid of three
and make it so that it says close line
and then here we can change open
to close
just like so
finally we need the other two buttons so
that would be
the ones we have here that we are going
to show within the larger screens
and to do that we are going to be using
anchor tags instead
the anchor tag is going to have the
class of list link again because i want
to share the same styles that the list
links have
then i'm going to have an additional
class of screen
sm
hidden
and this is going to do the opposite
which is just going to hide this
particular item on smaller screens
and then here we can say sign in
and then copy this underneath
and here we want to add an additional
class
of btn
and then
sign up
btn
and we'll also add a class here of fancy
border just like so
and inside of here we are going to copy
the text
then remove it
and then place a span inside of it
followed by
the text and this is going to be pretty
much it
for the navigation so the next step
would be to go inside of the css file
so that we can make this look a lot
better so let's go inside of the assets
css and then main dot css
and here it's going to be the same deal
we have several comments for each
individual section
and then i'm importing the google font
of pop-ins that we are going to be using
so let's go ahead and initialize some
custom properties
inside of the root pseudo class
and this just means that any variable
that i initialize in here is going to be
available for use within the css file so
think of it as global scoping
as far as the naming convention you want
to start with two hyphens and then the
name of the variable so i'm going to
call this one light
color
just like so
and then we simply store the value of
the color that we want
we will have another one this one will
be
light color alt
and then it will have the following hex
of a
fb
6c
d
then we will have another one down here
and this one is going to be for the
primary background color
and it's going to have the following
value
so this one is going to be 13
14
and then 17.
and that's pretty much how it goes but
let me just demo quickly something like
for example if you wanted to store a
font
in this situation let's say that
this is the font
family variable that i want to create
and then i just simply do the same thing
that i normally would and store the
value of pop-ins
and that's pretty much all there is to
it
now i don't want to bore you by having
you watch me type every single one of
them so i'm just going to speed up the
process and then i'm going to include
all the imports as well as the custom
properties within the starter files just
to make it easier for you to follow
along so i'll be right back
alright so now that the custom
properties are set let's go ahead and
apply some base styles
in here what i like to do is that i
start by using the universal selector
then i go ahead and i apply a margin of
0
a padding of 0
and then the box sizing
i set it to border box
and this just makes it so that
the math when sizing your elements is
going to be a lot simpler since
everything such as borders and paddings
is going to be calculated on the inside
of the element as opposed to the outside
of it
then i'm going to select
the html document
and i'm going to set a font size of 10
pixels
and the reason why i do this is because
i prefer using ram units as you can see
from here and this is just going to be a
lot better for responsive design and by
making it 10 pixels it's just going to
make the math a lot simpler so for
example if i wanted to do 16 pixels it's
as simple as just doing 1.6 ram so
that's what i mean
that being said i also want to do
the font size in percentages instead
the reason being because it's going to
scale a lot better when we use the zoom
that we have here within the browser
so 10 pixels in percentages is going to
be 62.5 percent so i'm just going to
comment this one out and keep it as a
reference
now we are going to select the body
and then here what i want to do is apply
the font family custom property
so to apply a custom property all you
have to do is just use var
and then inside of the parentheses what
you want to do is pass in the name of
the variable that you created so in this
situation we will use bond to family
because that's the name of the variable
then as far as the font size we will do
the same thing
and you don't actually have to type in
var every time at least if you're using
visual studio code
so in this case all you have to do is
just type in the name of the variable
itself
so for example i can type in font and
you see that we already get some
suggestions
i'm going to be using the sm font size
here so if i just hit enter or select it
you see that it already does it for us
then as far as the color this one is
going to be the light color
alt
and then the background color is going
to be the primary background color
then here i'm going to set a letter
spacing of 1 pixel followed by a
transition
which is going to be on the background
color
and it will be over 0.25 seconds
i also want to transition
the color over 0.25 seconds as well
and this transition is only there for
when we toggle between the themes so
that we get that really nice animation
then i'm going to select all of the
anchor tags
and i'm going to get rid of the text
decoration
by saying none
then i'm going to set the color to be
inherited from its
parent i'm going to select all of my
images
and i'm going to give them a max width
of 100
this is going to make it so that the
images will not overflow their parent
container
and then a display of block
i'm going to select all of my uls
and i'm just going to do a list style
of none
i'm going to select my inputs
as well as my buttons
and the font here is going to be
inherited
so if we hover over and this should be
button not buttons so if we hover over
the the property here it just tells us
that it's a shorthand for font style
font variant font weight font size and
so on
then what i want to do here is apply
a color that is going to be inherited
from its parent as well
then the border
will be set to none
then the background color is going to be
transparent
and i'm also going to get rid of the
outline here
finally i'm going to select
all of my i tags
and in here i just want to set a font
size which is going to be md
so font size
md
just like so
and now we can go ahead and add the
colors for the live theme so what we are
basically just going to do
is invert some of the variables that we
have right here and that's going to take
care of everything else for us
so here what i want to do is select the
body and say that when the body has the
light theme class
i want the following styles to have the
following values
and we are going to start with the light
color
and in fact it's going to be a lot
easier if i just copy
it so we need
primary secondary so let me just grab
all these for now
and we'll paste them here
then we also need the hover light color
and we will need the transparent dark
and transparent light colors
so now we can go ahead and change the
values
so this one here
is going to have the following which is
3d
and
then for the light color alt
this one is going to be
switched to a transparent color so this
is going to be rgba
and then we want a black color so we do
0 0 0 and then for the alpha or
transparency we do 0.6
for the primary background color we're
going to be switching this to white
and then for the secondary background
color this is going to be a lighter
shade of gray
so this one will be f1 f1 f1
then for the hover light color what we
want to do here is just set this to
white
as
well
and for the transparent dark color
we want to set this one to a solid so we
will use the color
of the secondary background color that
we have right here
just like so
finally the last one will stay the same
except that we are going to make the
transparency a lot more so we'll just do
0.1 there
let's now set up the reusable classes
and we will start by using the class of
container
and as i mentioned this is going to
limit how wide a certain element is
going to stretch to so i'm going to make
this 160 ram
then when we have enough space i also
want to center this container in the
middle so i'm going to be using a margin
top and bottom of zero
and auto left and right and then i'm
going to create some spacing on the
sides by giving it a padding 0 top and
bottom
and 1.5 left and right
i'm going to target the place item
center class
and in here i'm going to be using
flexbox
this is going to be inline
lex
then i want to align items to the center
and justify content
to the center as well
and
there's still a few more things in here
that we will target but we won't do that
till later on
so for now let's just stick to the
classes that we have defined
so in this case i'm going to select the
screen
sm hidden
and this is going to have a display
set to none simply because we are
starting mobile first and by default we
don't want to see anything with this
class
so now let's go ahead and work on the
header
let's select the header element
and here we are going to apply a
background color which is going to be
the secondary background color
then the position is going to be fixed
what we want to do next is give it a
starting top position of zero
and we will do the same for the left
then we will give this a width of a
hundred percent because since we made it
fixed and now lost its width
and then finally we will give it a c
index of a high value just so that we
make sure that it stays on top of all
the content
now i'm going to target the nav bar
and here i'm going to set the display to
be a flex
i want to align my items to the center
and then i want to justify my content
to space between
and that's going to give us some
separation here between the items
just like you can see there
so let me just bring this back
and i also want to add some spacing on
the top and bottom so for that i'm going
to be using padding and we can do a
padding block
of 1.5 ram as well
then i'm going to select the logo
and the logo is going to have the font
size
of font size md
and the color is going to be white so we
will use the light color
i will now select the menu
and i'm going to give this a position of
absolute
the starting top position i want to
position it under the header so this is
going to be 8.5 ram
for the right i'm going to do the same
spacing that i had
for the container just so that it lines
up
and then i'm going to do a width
of 23 run
then a padding all around
and a background color which is going to
be the secondary background color
and here we want to set the opacity to
zero
however opacity only has the element
from view
if i hover over it you can see that
everything is still clickable which
means it's still there
so what we want to do next is transform
scale
and we set that to zero and it's going
to shrink it all the way down so it's no
longer
clickable
and obviously we want to still see the
menu since we're working on it this is
going to be for javascript purposes
later on when we hide it and show it so
for the time being let's go ahead and
comment that out
then we want a transition here which is
going to be for the same purpose of
showing and hiding the menu
on the opacity
over 0.25 seconds
ease in
now i'm going to select the list
and the list is going to have a display
of flex
then i want to align my items to the
center as well
and i want to set some spacing so i will
use a gap
here as well
and even though it's not looking quite
right
the solution to fix this is by applying
a flex direction
of column
however i don't want to do this here
because remember that we have multiple
lists so if i applied it to this list
then it means that it's going to apply
it to every single element that has the
same class and that's not what we want
so let's go ahead and remove this
and instead i'll specifically apply it
to the element that i want to
in this case it's going to be the list
that is a direct child of the menu
element
just like so
and if we go back to the html document
here you can see that this list is a
direct child of this menu element
so what i want to do next is select the
list link that is current
so for this we just make sure that we
chain the two classes together
and here what we want to do is change
the color
so the color here is going to be the
light color
so now what's different well slightly
different from the rest of them
next i'm going to remove the close menu
icon which is going to be the x
so let's select the close menu icon
and give this a display
of none
now i'm going to select all the btns
and what i want to do here is set the
cursor to bf pointer so that when we
hover over the buttons we get the
appearance that it's clickable
i now want to set some hover effects so
i'm going to select the list link
on hover
and the following styles
are going to be applied so this is just
going to be a change of color
which is going to be transitioning
to the light
color
custom property that we have
so if we go ahead and try that out you
can see that it works
however we still want to apply the same
effect to
the buttons
and we want to apply it to the span
inside of the buttons as well
so we'll do btn hover
and then the span inside of it
and
one more thing that i want to do now is
hide the moon icon because by default we
are going to be within the dark theme so
we only want to see the sun icon
and we'll just set the display property
here to none
now i'm going to select the live theme
and then the sun icon
and this is going to have a display of
none
and this just means that when the body
has the life theme class then the sun
icon we no longer want to see it the one
that we do want to see is going to be
the moon icon
so we're going to grab this and we'll
repeat it for the live theme
and then the moon icon
and the only difference here is that we
change this one to block so that we show
it
now you're not going to be seeing that
in play right now but you will later
once we get into the javascript portion
which is going to be shortly but before
that let's set up the styles that we are
going to trigger once we get to the
javascript portion
so that's going to be down here
and the first thing that i want to do is
add a box shadow to this header once we
start scrolling
so let's target the header
and then we'll say that when the header
is activated or when it has the class of
activated
we want to apply a box shadow
which is going to have
a value of 0 for the x offset
1 pixel for the y offset and then 0.5
ram for the blur and spread
and then it's going to have a
transparent
light color
now we're going to do something similar
here for the menu so let's just copy
that
and let's change header to menu
so this is going to be slightly
different now because we are going to
have one pixel here for the x offset as
well
and then we'll just change this to one
and the rest can remain the same
so remember that i said that first we
hide this and then we show it on click
so this is where it comes into play
so let's uncomment that out now
and then we are going to copy it
and we'll paste it down here
then we just change the zero
to ones
just like so
then we also want to be able to switch
the icons
so the next thing that i'm going to do
is select the menu toggle icon
and we are going to say
that when it's activated
let's remove the menu class from here
because we don't need it
so when it's activated
we want to target the open menu icon
and in here we want to set the display
to none
then we'll do the same thing
for the x
so let's change
open to close
and then this one will be block because
we do want to show it
so let's go ahead and open up the
javascript file
and in here what i'm going to do is
define a function that is going to allow
us to select elements
very easily and this is going to work
similar to how jquery does it
uh by the way shout out to john from
coding addict this is the method that he
uses it's actually pretty useful
so we'll start by declaring a function
expression
and i'm going to call it select element
and then in here we can have a parameter
of selector
you can call this whatever you want
and
it will be an arrow function
and what we want to do in here is define
another variable this one i'm going to
call element
and then i'm going to store
the value of whatever we pass in
into this element variable so
document
query selector
and now we pass in the selector
then what we want to do is add in some
validation so we'll say if element
meaning whether it's true or false
in this case if it's true we want to
return the element
if not what we can do is throw an error
so we'll say throw new error
and then we'll use dibectix
and
in here we can have a custom error
message
so i'm going to type in something went
wrong
make sure
that
the selector
this is going to make sure that it tells
you which selector it is that is
wrong or typed incorrectly
based on what we passed in
so make sure that the selector
exists
or is typed
correctly
just like so so now we can go ahead and
test that out so we'll call the select
element function
and we are going to pass in an element
that we know is valid so in this case
the navbar
let's also console.log that
so let's go ahead and open up the
console
and see if we get the
element that we want and we do so here
we have the nav element
now let's see what happens if we add in
an element that doesn't exist so let's
say footer
and now you see that we get the error
something went wrong make sure that
footer exists or is typed correctly
so now that we know that this is working
we can get rid of this console log
and we can move on so now we can go
ahead and add the styles that are going
to trigger on scroll to the header
so for this i'm going to have another
function
i will call this one scroll header
and then what i'll do
is have another arrow function here
and i'm going to define a variable
called
navbar
element
and then i'm going to call the select
element function
and pass in the header id
and i shouldn't call this one navbar
element
i should have called that header element
then
underneath what i want to do is have an
if statement to check if the scroll has
passed a certain point
and if it does then we want to do
something in this case add a class and
if not we want to remove that class
so we'll say if
then we will use the this keyword since
this
function is going to be attached to the
window object
scroll y
and then we want to check
if it's greater or equal to
15.
if it is
we want to add a class and if not we
want to remove that class so we'll say
header
element
class list
and then
add
activated
so let's go ahead and grab that
paste it underneath
and remove
add and add remove
and then we'll scroll to the end here
and we're going to add a demo element so
i'm going to say search
and then within the css i'm going to
select it and give it a really high
height
so search
and the height is going to be
2000 rem
and now we get the scroll bars and we
can test that out so obviously it's not
working because we still haven't called
the function
so for that we are going to attach an
event listener
to the window object
which is going to be a scroll
and then we just simply pass in
this scroll header function
and now if you go ahead and test it out
you can see that it shows up it's really
subtle so you can't see it all that much
let me actually demonstrate by
by adding a background color here
of red
so now once we scroll past that 15 you
see that we get the background color of
red and if we go back to the start it
goes to the normal color
so this is working
so let's now go ahead and get rid of
this as well as this since we no longer
need it
and then we can move along and keep
working on the rest
so the next thing that i want to do now
is open and close the menu
so we're going to do that down here
we're going to start by defining a
variable which is going to be called
menu
toggle
icon
and then here we just call the select
element function again
and we pass in the id of menu toggle
icon
then what we want to do is create
another function which i'm going to call
toggle menu
and this will be another arrow function
and in here what i want to do is just
toggle some classes
so mobile
well first let me define
a variable so that we can store the menu
element inside of it i'm going to call
this one mobile menu
and then we call the select element
function once more
pass in the id of menu
and now we can do something with it
so mobile menu
classlist
toggle
and then
what we can do in here
is say that we want to toggle
activated
and then what we want to do is just
toggle the class list on the menu toggle
icon
which is going to be the same one
now we're going to call the function
then add event listener
this one is going to be a click
event and we go ahead and pass in the
menu toggle function that we created
actually it's the other way around
toggle menu
so now if we test that out
it should be in working order
there we go
and notice how the icons are being
switched as well
since we're already here let's go ahead
and add the functionality to switch
between the themes so let's start by
defining a variable called
body element
and then we can just store the body
element itself we don't have to call the
function here we can just simply do body
i mean
document.body and that's going to work
the same way
i need to also create one for the theme
toggle btn
and then i'm going to call the function
here
and store
the theme
toggle
btn in here
then i'm going to add an event listener
to this theme toggle btn variable
and what we want to do in here is toggle
the the class the
the light theme class on the body so
we're going to use the body element
class list
toggle
and then
light theme
and this should work now
so if you click it you see that the
theme changes and the icons as well
but if i refresh the page notice how it
disappears and that's because now we
have to add it into local storage so
that the theme selection is saved so how
do we do that
well as i mentioned after we click this
button
the body is going to have the class list
of like theme toggled
so what we have to do now is add some if
statements
so here we are going to say that if the
body element
class list contains
the class of lysine
so again it's saying if the body
currently has the class of life's theme
then we want to do something
and that something is that we want to
set
this theme within local storage
so we'll select the local storage
interface and then we'll call the set
item method
and here we just basically have a key
value pair
and in this situation the first value
that we pass in this is going to be the
key name
so let me just call this current theme
and then
for the name of the value itself we can
just call this
theme active
and then for the else condition
we just want to remove
this item from local storage
if the class is not present
so we are going to call this
paste it down here and as opposed to
saying instead item
we just say remove
item
and then
we just need
the current theme here
but that's not going to be enough yet so
let's test it out if i refresh it you
see that it's still gone
so what we have to do now is get the
item that is currently stored within
local storage so for that let me define
another variable up here
and this one i'm going to call it
current theme
and then what we want to do now is get
that item from local storage so we say
local storage
and then we use the get item method to
get
the current theme that we have stored
within local storage so here we just
pass in the name
of the
key that we have here
and what i put this over here so here we
just say current
theme
now again
that alone is not
enough to do anything
so we have to add in another if
statement and we're going to be doing
this outside
so here what we are going to do is say
that
if there is the current theme within
local storage so we we can just say
current theme
so if this occurring theme present
we want to make sure that the body has
that live theme class
so again we will just say body element
and then class list
add
like theme
so let's go ahead and test that out well
as you can see it's already within local
storage so it just changed automatically
after visual studio
refresh the browser with live server
so as you can see the theme selection is
still there
same thing will happen if we refresh
from the dark theme so let's quickly go
over again what we did
so we defined a variable here to store
the body element
then we did the same thing for the theme
toggle btn
then here we just basically get the
current item that we stored
within local storage
then in this if statement we check if
there's a current item so a current
theme in this situation and if there is
the body element will get the class of
light theme which is going to trigger
the light theme styles
here within the event listener when this
btn is clicked what will happen is that
the body element is going to have the
light theme added
or removed
depending on if you double click it or
not and again we check if the body
element has that class and if it does
it's going to be set within local
storage and if it's not it's going to be
removed
so that's basically everything we did
there the next step is going to be going
inside of the index.html so that we can
work on the search portion of this
project
so we'll continue here by having a div
with the class of search form
container
as well as the class of container and
the id
of search form container
just like so
then inside we are going to have a div
with the class of form container
enter
and inside of here we will have the form
itself
so the form is going to have the class
of form
the action can be left empty for now
since this form is not functional
and then inside of the form we will have
an input that will have the class of
form input
this input is going to be of type of
text
and it will have a placeholder that will
say
what are you looking for
underneath we are going to have a button
with a class of btn and the class of
form btn
and this button is going to be of type
submit
then as far as the inside i'm going to
be placing here a icon
and this icon is going to have the class
of ri
and then search
line
just like so so for the time being we
can't see it but that's because it's
under this
then underneath the form we are going to
have the text that is going to be for
the
or press escape to close so that would
be
this right here
and this span
is going to have the class
a form
note
and then we can just say or press
escape
to close
so now outside of this form container
enter we are going to have another
button
this button is going to have the class
of btn
form
close
btn
the class of place
items center
and then the id
of form
close
btn
just like so
and then we'll just put in the x
icon
so we'll do ri
close
line
just like so so now we can see some of
it underneath
and this is going to be it for the form
what we are going to do next is go
inside of the
main.css so that we can style it
and we are going to begin by selecting
the search form container
this is going to have a width of a
hundred percent
the height is going to be
100 of the bh
and i'm also going to set a max width
here of a hundred percent
then the background color is going to be
the primary background color
let me get rid of that spacing there
and now the position is going to be
fixed
top starting position will be 0
left will be 0 as well
c index is going to be a really really
high value because i want this to be at
the top of everything
then display will be set to flex
then the opacity here
is going to be set to
zero
the transform scale
is going to be set to zero
and then we want to transition
the opacity
and it's going to be over 0.5 seconds
now the same concept as before let's
comment this out for now because we
still need to see what we're doing with
this form
and then we can continue underneath
so now i'm going to select the
warm container enter
and this is going to have a margin of
auto and that's just going to center it
in the middle just like so
then this will have a display of flex
flex direction
will be column
and then i'll add a gap for spacing
and then i want to text the line to the
center
now i'm going to select the form itself
and this will just have a display of
flex as well
and then i want to justify my content
to the center to place it in the middle
then i'm going to select the inputs the
form input
as well as the form btn because these
styles they will have it in common
here i'm going to give this a display
of inline block
just so that it respects the paddings
and margins on top
then i'm going to give this a border
of two pixels
solid
and then it's going to be the secondary
background color
so now it's taking shape
then i want to make them a little bit
larger so i'm going to give it a padding
all around
and then the color
well i'm already inheriting the color
here so i don't have to do anything
the next thing that i'm going to do is
select the form input by itself
and i want to add the following styles
so the first one is going to be a border
right
which is going to be of none
then what i want to do is give it a
width of 100
then the background color is going to be
the primary background color
because as it is it's going to be
transparent and in this situation i
guess we could do without having a
background color here since the parent
already has it
so we can just get rid of this actually
now let's select the form btn
this is going to have a margin left
which is going to be negative 0.5 ram
and that's just going to push it a
little bit to the left
then as far as the border left
we can get rid of it
then for the background color here
we can just set the secondary background
color
and
we can do a width
of 8 ram
just like so
now as far as the form note
we can do a font size of
extra small
and then i want to
basically align it all the way to the
left so for that i can just do align
self
and then flex end
then i'm going to select the form close
btn
and here i'm going to give it a position
of absolute
top is going to be 1.5 ram
the right is going to be 1.5 ram as well
then the border
is going to be 2 pixels
solid
and then we can just do the secondary
background color here as well
then as far as the width we can do 4 ram
the height is going to be for ram as
well
and then what we can do
is
give this a display of flex
although never mind i think we already
took care of that with the
place items center class so we don't
need this
because i was just going to do align
items
center and justify content center
but since that class is already doing
that for us we don't need it
so now we can go ahead and make this
functional
meaning by
removing and showing this form whenever
we click on the search icon
and to do so let's set up the styles
for the form
so what we are going to do here is say
search form container
and then when it has the class of
activated
we want to set the opacity back to 1 and
the transform scale
back to 1 as well
so remember we commented this out let's
uncomment it out again
and now we get the default behavior so
when we go and set up the javascript
portion for this when we click this
button the
form should show up
so let's go ahead and do that right now
let's scroll all the way down here
and what we are going to do is set up
some variables
so the first one is going to be for the
form
open
btn
and then we call the select element
function
and we pass in
the id of search icon
then we're going to duplicate this a
couple more times below
this one is going to be for the form
close btn
and the last one is going to be for the
search
worm container
now all we have to do is just switch up
the variables
form
let's say
search form container instead
and for this one we can just switch open
to close
then underneath of here what i'm going
to do
is have an event listener that i'm going
to be attaching to the form
open btn
and this event listener is going to be
of click
then
here we can just have an arrow function
and since we only have one line we don't
really need to use the curly braces here
so we can just straight up say
search
form container
class list
and then
add
and what we can do here is
say that we want to add the class of
activated
so if we go ahead and test that out now
it should work
so it pops up
if we click it it's still there because
we still have to add the other event
listener
so for that it's going to be very simple
i'm just going to duplicate the other
one down below
then switch
close
open i should say switch open to close
and then as opposed to adding we remove
so now if i click it it should open and
if i click this button it should be gone
so the
last thing we have to do here is make
this functional by removing the class
when we hit the escape key
and to do that what we can do
is set an event listener on the window
object so we can say window out event
listener and this event listener is
going to be of key up
and then we can just have an error
function here
and
since it's only one parameter we can
just
uh forget about the parentheses here and
just do the parameter itself
and in this case i'm just going to call
this one event
and i'm missing the parentheses here for
the event listener
and then here what we want to do is set
up an if statement and this if statement
is going to check whether the key of
escape has been pressed so for that we
can say event dot key
and then if it's equal to escape
then we want to do something in this
case what we want to do is search
form container
class list
remove
i guess we could have just copied it
from here but
it's too late already
activated
so let's go ahead and test that out
so if we click it it will open if we hit
the escape key it's now closed
so that's pretty much all there is to
this portion of the javascript uh the
last thing that we are going to be doing
here is for swiper js
but we're not there yet so we're not
going to worry about it for now
the thing that we do have to do now is
go back inside of the
index.html so that we can work on the
featured articles section
so let's select the section element and
then we can apply a class of featured
articles
as well as a class of section
header
offset
inside of here we will have a div with
the class of featured
articles
container
and then another class of container
can get this right
and a third class of the grid
so the grid class is going to turn any
element into a grid container
and it's also going to be another one of
our reusable classes
then inside of here i'm going to have a
nested grid
so this one is going to have the class
of featured content
as well as the grid
so in here i want to have a div
this div is going to have the class of
headline banner
and inside of it i'm going to have the
headline itself so this is going to be
nh3 that has the class of headline and
the class of fancy border
inside of it we will have a span and the
span is going to have the class of place
items
center
and then for the text it will be
breaking news
underneath we are going to have another
span
this one with the class of headline
description
and then we can say apple
announces
a new
partnership
underneath of the headline banner we are
going to have all of the cards
so for this we will use an anchor tag
this anchor tag is going to have the
class of article
then it will have the class a featured
article
and then an additional class a featured
article
1
then we can just link to the post page
and then we can move on
so inside of here
i'm going to have an image this image is
going to have the class of article image
and the image that i want to use is
going to be inside the assets folder
images folder
the featured folder
and then featured one
under the image i'm going to have a span
and this span is going to have the class
of article category
and for the text here we can just use
anything
so underneath of the span i'm going to
have another wrapper div and this one is
going to have the class of article data
container
inside of it i'm going to have another
div this one is going to be for the
article data
and i'll have three spans in here
so
what i want to do is
add some text in here
and then for the middle one we can add a
class
of
article data
spacer
and then the last one will be the
estimated read time
finally underneath we are going to have
an h3
and this h3 is going to have the class
of title as well as the class of article
title
sbr
the future
and that's going to be the base for
every single card that we have
so let's go ahead and copy this one
and we can paste it underneath three
more times
well two more times since we only have
three of them
and now we can just go ahead and change
the data so for this one we can change
the image to number two
as well as the featured article to
number two
and then the last one will be three
just like so
so now i'm deleting whether i should go
inside of the css and make this portion
look better
or if i should add in the rest which is
going to be the sidebar
so for now i'm guessing that i can just
go ahead and
just do the css for this portion and
then i can come back once i do that so
let's go inside of the css now
and let's make this look better
so let's go all the way back up to the
reusable classes and
what i'm going to do here
is find the reusable classes comment and
i'm going to add in the grid class
then i'm also going to add a class for
the sections which we still haven't used
and i'm going to add padding top and
bottom here so i'm just going to use the
padding block instead
i was going to do this later but might
as well just do it now and get it out of
the way
so now here what we want to do is select
the featured
articles
and i'm going to give this a padding
block
of to rem
then i'm going to select
the section header offset
and this is going to have a margin top
of 7.4 ram and that's going to push the
content down underneath of the header
the next thing that i want to do is
select
the featured articles container
as well as the featured content
since they both share the same gap
underneath i'm going to select the
headline banner
and this will have a background color of
secondary background color
display
will be flex
align
items will be center
and then to create some separation
between the two texts i'm going to also
give this a gap
and then the font size is going to be
extra small
now i'm going to select the
headline by itself
and
this is going to have a color
which is going to be the light color
then i'm going to give this a font size
of one ram
text transform
of uppercase
and then
text online is going to be center
then i'm going to give it some padding
of
0.4 ram
and a height
of a hundred percent
i'm now going to select the headline
span
and this is going to
have a height that is inherited
and i'm giving this a position of
relative
as well as the overflow
of hidden
then underneath i'm going to select the
fancy border once more
and i'm going to create a pseudo element
so we have to add in the content which
is going to be an empty string if we
don't add this then the element is not
going to show up
then the position of absolute op
starting position 0
same thing for the left
and then the width is going to be
double so i'm going to do 200 percent
just so that this element is twice as
large
then the height is going to be a hundred
percent
then the background is going to be
the gradient color
then the background size
will be 50
100
so now we get a nicer
layout here for the background colors
then i'm going to give this ac index
which is going to be 5
and then underneath i'm going to select
the fancy border span
and this is going to have a position of
relative because i want to add a c index
of 10 so that it sends the text to the
top
of the background
then this is going to get a display of
inline block
actually i'm going to do display in
light flex
and then i'm going to set a padding
which is going to be
0.6 top and bottom
1.5 left and right
finally i'm going to give this a
background color which is going to be
the secondary background color
now don't mind too much that it looks
squished up there the reason why it
looks like that is because i'm zooming
in 150 percent if i made the smaller you
see that it looks just fine
so the next thing that i'm going to do
now is select the article
title actually before i select the
article title let me actually style the
article itself so the article here is
going to have the position of relative
since i'm going to have some elements
that will have position absolute inside
of it
then i'm going to study min height so
this is the minimum height that each
item is going to have
and for that we will use the variable of
item in height md
then i'm going to select the article
image
and this will have a position of
absolute
then i'm going to give this a width of
100
the height of 100 as well
and then we can do object fit
of cover
just so that the image is going to scale
a lot better within its box
then i'm going to do a transition on the
transform
over 0.25 seconds and this is going to
be for the hover effect where the image
is zoomed in when we hover over it
this knot this isn't going to take
effect now but it will later down the
line
so the next thing that i want to target
is the article category
and this will have the position of
absolute
top is going to be one ram
bright
one rem as well
then padding all around will also be one
rem
one size one rem
and then the background color
is going to be the primary background
color
next i'm going to set a color of light
and i'm going to also set a text
transform
of uppercase
followed by a c index of 10.
the next thing that i'm going to style
is the article data container
and this will have a position of
absolute as well
because we are going to be positioning
it to the bottom
and then
the bottom is going to be set to 0
left
0 as well
padding is going to be 2 ram top and
bottom
1.5 ram left and right
background color is going to be the
transparent background color
and it should be dark color not the
light one
and then you see index here as well of
10 just so that it stays on top of the
other content now since we have the
position of absolute here it's only
taking up as much space as it needs
so let's make sure that we also give
this a width of 100
just like so we also want to add a hover
effect here so let's add a transition
so that the hover is animated and this
will be on the background color
and it will be over 0.5 seconds
just like so
so the
next thing that i'm going to do is add
the hover effects themselves
so i'm going to select the article and
i'll say that when the article is
covered i want to target the article
data container
so the background color here is now
going to be the hover
background color for the dark color
and then the color itself is going to be
hover light color
so if you go ahead and try that out
you see that we now get the solid
background color here
now let's target the article data
and what we want to do here is give this
a display of flex
and then we want to align items to the
center
then we will apply a gap for separation
and then we are going to apply a font
size which is going to be extra small
finally i'm going to add a margin bottom
for additional separation between
this text and the title
and it's going to be
one ram
just excel
now we are going to generate the article
spacer
and this will have a width of 0.5 ram
height of 0.5 ram as well
then the background color
is going to be the light color alt
and finally what we want to do is rotate
it by 45 degrees so transform
rotate
45 degrees
and that's now going to look more like a
little diamond
and the next thing that i want to target
now is going to be
well as you can see the hover effect is
not applying to this element
so what we have to do
is come back here
and then we can get rid of this
we can switch
this over to
well i got rid of the curly brace there
for
no reason
but now we switch dark to light and we
switch this to
[Music]
the spacer class
and now if we hover over it it should
work and it does
so let's go back down and let's now
style the title
the title is going to have the color
of light color
and now you see the difference between
this text and the title when it's not
being hovered
and one last thing is going to be the
article title itself
and this is just going to have a font
size of md
just like
so so next we are going to work on the
sidebar but before we actually do
anything with the css what we have to do
is jump back inside of the index.html
so that we can write the markup for it
so let me make a comment here
sidebar
and under here we are going to start by
having a div with the class of sidebar
as well as the grid
and then inside of it we will have an h3
this h3 is going to have the class of
title
and featured
content
title
trending news
and should only be trending
then here we are going to have the card
itself for this we will use an anchor
tag again with the class of trending
news
box
so we can use a placeholder there
and then inside of it we will have a div
with a class of trending use image box
inside of here we will have a span
that has the class of trending
number
we will have an additional class of
place
items
center
and then this is going to be 0 1
then we will have the image that will
have the class of article image
we can go inside of the assets folder
images folder and then trending
and it's going to be the first image
underneath of the trending news image
box we are going to have another div and
this div is going to have the class of
trending use data
and we already have the base for this
article data since we are going to
repeat it so let's just copy that
and we can paste it in here
underneath we are going to have an h3
and this h3 is going to have the class
of title
as well as the class of article
title
we already had this as well so i guess
we could have copied it but kind of late
now
then we can just do sample
article
idle
just excel
and
again this is the base for each
individual card that we are going to
have
so we can just copy the anchor tag
and then we can just paste it underneath
as many times as we need
so in this case we had a five
and that should be the last one so now
we can just go ahead and change the
images
four
three
and
two
because we already have one at number
one
let's also go ahead and change the text
and this is going to be number four
and finally
number five so that's going to be it for
each individual card that we are going
to have inside of the sidebar
so it's going to be the same deal now
what we have to do is go inside of the
css so that we can style it
so let's go ahead and select the sidebar
this will have a background color which
is going to be the secondary background
color
padding all around of 2.5 rem
then underneath i'm going to select the
trending use box
this will have a display of flex
flex direction
column and then the gap for separation
and underneath i'm also going to add
some padding top and bottom so i'm going
to do padding block
up to ram
then finally i'm going to add a border
which is going to be 1 pixel
solid
and then
it's going to be the transparent
light color
and um now i'm going to select the
trending news box which is the last one
so trending
news box
last of type
and what we are going to do is that what
we are going to get rid of this border
bottom
so border bottom
none
and i know you can't see it right now
but that's because um we haven't added
the position of relative to this
image box that we have here
but we're going to be taking care of
that right now
so trending
news
image box
now you'll see that the moment i give it
the position of relative it's going to
fix itself
and that's because
this image right here if you remember
correctly this particular class we added
the position of absolute so it just
needed the class of relative so that
this image would be positioned
absolutely relative to this div
so if we go back in here
i'm going to give this a width
of a hundred percent
then i'm going to give it a height
and this height is going to be the item
in height sm
and now i'm going to go ahead and select
the featured
content title
and this will have a font size of md
it will also have a taxon line of center
and then a padding all around of one ram
next i'm going to select the trending
number this will have a position of
absolute
and then the top
negative one ram
left is going to be negative one ram as
well
c index of 15. then a width of 3 ram
height is going to be 3 rem as well
the background color is going to be the
secondary background color
and then the color itself is going to be
the light color
what i want to do next is give it a
border radius of 50
to make it round
just like so
and the last thing that i'm going to do
here is select the trending news data
article title
article title
and this is going to have a font size of
sm
i'm also going to add a hover effect
here so
trending
news box
unhover i want to target the article
title
and then the color here is going to be
the light
color
well first we have to specify that it's
a color
before we actually use the variable
so light color
and it's going to be the alt
just like so
so now you see that if we hover over it
we get the effect that we want so let's
compare with the original
as you can see this one is still
i'm slightly smaller
so let me double check
that
well the reason is because this one is
at 150
percent the original that i have here
for the demo is at 150 percent
and then the original project is at a
hundred percent so if we make it the
same size
you see that
now they both
look pretty similar
and except for the text right here
because i'm just doing the same one that
i had before from copying and pasting
again text doesn't really matter that
can easily be changed
so
now the next part is going to be working
on the quick read section
so back inside of the index.html what we
are going to do here is layout the
markup
so first let's begin by having a section
element
that will have the class of
quick read
and it will also have a class of section
inside of it i'm going to have the class
of container
and then in here i'm going to have an h2
with the class of title
and then a class of section
title
i'm also going to apply a data attribute
here
so i'm going to call this one data name
and what i'm going to say inside of here
is the name
of this elements which is going to be
the quick read
and then inside of here i'm going to
have
the the same thing
and that's because we have over here the
the title set up this way where we have
a faded one that is going to be slightly
larger in the back and for that we are
just going to be using this data element
within the pseudo element
so
maybe i should just bring this over back
one line
just like so
and now we can lay out the markup for
the swiper
so
in order to start this we are going to
have a div
that will have the class of swiper
and these are all the the swiper classes
so this is basically the the structure
for a swiper
carousel
then i'm going to have a div that will
have the class of swiper wrapper
inside of here i'm going to have each
individual card
so this one is going to have
the class of article
because we still want to share those
styles of the article
and then it needs the swiper class of
swiper
slide
then inside of here well we can just use
a placeholder there
and inside of the anchor tag we are
going to have an image this image is
going to have the class of article image
then we can go inside of the assets
folder
images folder
and then we can go inside of the quick
read folder
and we can grab the first image
then underneath this image we need
another article data container
and in fact what we can just do
is go and get it from the
first one that we had here so article
data container
so now we can just beat up the process
and paste it over here let me just make
sure that everything is correct so we
have the article data container
then inside of it we have the article
data
the spacer
and then the title itself
so that's going to be our first slide
let me just create some separation there
so that's more
readable so let's go ahead and add
another one
another one another one another one and
another one
so now what we have to do is just go
ahead and
add the images
so for the first one we already have
that image
covered
with a second one
we have number two
then we have number three
number four
number five
and
number six
and uh that's pretty much going to be
the structure for the slides what we are
going to do now is add
the navigation buttons which is going to
be the
right and left arrows as well as the
pagination controls
so we actually have to add those
underneath
of this div which is going to be
this swiper wrapper
and this will have the class
of swiper
button
breathe
so again
and this will have the class of swiper
button
breathe
and we also want to add an additional
class here of swiper controls now the
swiper controls class is my own class
that i will be using to style the arrows
then we can just go ahead and duplicate
this
down below
and then we can change this one to next
the last thing that we have to add is
the pagination as you can see the icons
are already showing up here
so for the pagination we have to add a
div that will have the class a swiper
pagination
just excel
so that's going to be it for this
particular section now the next step is
going to be going inside of the css
and we are going to make this look
slightly better and then we are going to
tackle the javascript portion
so down here we are going to select the
section title
and this is going to have the position
of relative
it's going to have the font size
of font size md
then a margin bottom
which is going to be six rem
and now i'm going to
create the pseudoelement for it so
section
and
title
before
actually i'll just use the after well
let's just keep before since it's
actually behind it
so as far as the content here what we
can do is
use the attribute
and then data name
just like so
so the font size here is going to be the
font size large
and then we can text transform to
uppercase
the opacity here is going to be 0.1
so that it's faded
and position is going to be
absolute
and then it will be positioned
1.4 1.5 ram
i should say from the top and then from
the left by two ram
so if we scroll a little bit up we
should be able to see that right here
now
then
i'm going to target the article
and then the swiper slide
so we have to do it this way
being more specific in order to actually
override some of the styles that the
swiper
css file has
so here the height is going to be 40 ram
just like so
so the next thing that i'm going to do
is
add some additional styles here
for the swiper wrapper
and the height is going to be auto
then the swiper controls
what i want to do here is give it a
width of 3.5
ram
i will do the same thing for the height
and then the background color is going
to be the secondary background color
then what i'll do is select the swiper
controls once more
and then what i want to do is select the
after pseudo element
that swiper actually creates
so the font size here is going to be 1.6
ram
and that's going to make the controls
smaller or the arrows i should say and
then for the color we are going to make
it white as opposed to blue
so we are going to use the light color
and you probably noticed that the
pagination bullet points are not showing
up and that's because for them to show
up we have to first initialize swiper so
let's go back inside of the main.js and
the first thing we have to do here is
define a constant variable
which we are going to call swiper and
then we have to create a new instance a
swiper
then in here
we can just select
the div that we have with the class of
swiper and then we can pass in some
options
so the way it works is by having key
value pairs
so to show a certain amount of slides
per view in this situation by default we
have one
so i'm going to set that here slides per
view
then we set that to the number that we
want
then the next value is going to be for
the spacing that i want between each
slide so the default spacing that i want
is going to be
20 so for this we use space
between
then here we are going to make
the arrows functional
so we have to set the navigation here
and we have to specify
the values so in this situation
for the next el property
what we want to set is the swiper class
for a particular button so this one is
going to be for the next element
so here we set the swiper
next
actually button
next
then we do the same thing for the
previous button so this one we can
change to preve
and then we have to change this one from
next to prev as well
and let's not forget to add a comma here
and one here as well
well this is the last one so we don't
need it there
we do need it here though so the next
thing that i want to add and make
functional is going to be the pagination
so for that
we say pagination and then we just set
that to the element that we have for the
pagination so that's going to be the div
that has the class of swiper pagination
and then here we just say el
and then we select the div with the
class of swiper agination
and
just like so now the pagination is
showing up
and this should work
already as you can see we can also drag
it
so the next thing that i want to add
here is going to be the responsive
breakpoint
so for this we can just specify that we
want to set breakpoints
and then here we can set various
different numbers so my breakpoints are
going to be 700
and in here what i want to do is just
show a certain amount
of slides per view
so let me just copy this
paste it in here
and i want to show two
then for the next breakpoint
let me just paste this one down below
this breakpoint is going to be 1200
and then i just want to show
all three slides
so if i go ahead and make this bigger
now you'll notice that it works just
fine
now we get two
and then we get three so that's working
exactly how we want it to work
so one more thing that i have to do is
style the bullet points here for the
pagination
so let me just minimize this
put this here to line it up
and now since we are done with the whole
swiper js thing what we can do is go
back inside of the css
and then here we can set the styles for
the bullet points
so i'm going to start here by selecting
the swiper pagination
and i'm going to give this a margin
bottom
while another margin bottom but a bottom
position
of 0.5 ram
and we also have to specify this is
important to override it from
the swiper css file
next i'm going to select the swiper
pagination
and then
bullet
so this is not an element that we
defined it's actually coming from the
swiper js css file and i just noticed
that i misspelled
bullet here
should be like this
and here we just change the background
color to the light color
and now everything is working exactly
how we want it to work
so the next step is going to be
going back inside of the
index.html so that we can work on the
older pose section
so let's scroll down and go inside of
this comment
so this section is going to be pretty
straightforward since we are going to be
reusing some of the elements that we
already created before
the only difference is that we are going
to have some slight modifications
so let's begin by using the section
element and then let's apply the class
of older posts
as well as the class of section
and inside of here we are going to have
a div with the class of container
and then followed by the h2 that has the
class of title as well as the class of
section
title
then here we can say older posts
and let's not forget the data attribute
so data
name
older
pose
so let's scroll that down it now shows
up here
then here we are going to have another
container this one is going to have a
class
folder
pose
grid
wrapper
as well as the class of the grid
and then here this is where we are going
to have each individual card
so again we will use an anchor tag with
the class of article as well as a class
of the grid since we also want to make
this particular card a grid container
then we can use a placeholder here
and then inside of it we are going to
have a div that has the class
older
pose
article
image
wrapper
i know that was a long one
then instead of there we are going to
have an image that has the class of
article image
and then the image that we want is going
to be inside of the assets folder images
folder
older pose and then it's going to be the
first image
underneath we are going to have the same
article data container that we had
before so let's actually
grab that instead
from
[Music]
here
and
the only difference here is that we are
going to have
ap tag that has the class of article
description
just like so
and then we can just generate some dummy
text
let me make that smaller
cut it about here
and now that we have the basic structure
we can just go ahead
copy this anchor tag and paste it down
below five times
just like so
and now the only thing we have to do is
just change the images so this one
should be six
this one five
four
three
and two
so now that we have all the cards here
with
each individual image
the last thing that we are going to do
here is
add in
the c-more button so underneath of here
we are going to have a div that has the
class of c-more
container
then inside we will have an anchor tag
that has the class of btn
c-more
btn
and place
items
center
then this can just be a placeholder and
then see more
followed
by the icon which is going to be the
arrow right
so ri
arrow
right
s
line
and now we are done with this section so
let's quickly go inside of the main.css
and let's make it look
better
so let's go ahead and select the older
post grid wrapper and let's apply a gap
and then we'll select the older post
article image wrapper
as well as the
older pose
article
then let's apply a min height which is
going to be the item and height of sm
now i'll select them individually so all
the post
article
and i will set a background color which
is going to be the secondary background
color
you're not going to see a show through
and that's because the article data
container already has a background color
but we're going to reset that later
so now i'll select the older post
article image wrapper
and i'm going to set the position here
to be of relative
then we are going to apply the reset to
the older post
grid wrapper
and then the article data container
so here we just reset the position to
static from absolute
and then here the background color is
going to be transparent
so now the secondary background color
should be shown through and that's
because we messed it up here we should
have selected
the article data container instead
so now it works
underneath of that i'm going to apply
some margin bottom to the article title
that is inside the article
the older posed creative wrapper i
should say
so article title
and this will have the margin bottom of
sm
and then down here i'm going to do the
same thing but it's going to be for the
c-more container
and what i'll do now is scroll all the
way to the bottom
and then i'm going to give this a margin
top instead
which is going to be the margin
md
and that's going to give us some
additional separation
next i'm going to select the c-more btn
and this is going to have a text
transform
of uppercase
then i'm going to select the c-more
button on hover
and um i don't think i do need one
though yeah because i already have it
applied globally
so let's just leave that out
so what i do want to set
wait yes so what i do want to set is the
animation when we hover over it that the
arrow is going to move a little bit to
the right
so to do that what i have to do is say
see
more
and then
the icon
and i want to set a transition here
which is going to be on the transform
over 0.25 seconds
and now i can say that when the c-more
btn is hovered
i want to target the icon inside of it
and then i want to transform
translate
x
over 0.5 ram
so let's test that out
and as you can see there it works
so that's going to be it for this
particular section the next one is going
to be the popular tags so let's go back
inside of the index.html
and let's find the popular tags comment
so let's go ahead and add the section
element
and then add the class of popular
tags
as well
as a class of section
then inside of it we will have a div
with the class of container
and then we will have the same title
that we have been reusing
so let's just be a little bit lazy here
and copy this portion as well as this
one
then we'll scroll back to the bottom
and then we'll paste it in
and let's close this one off just like
so
so for this one we are going to change
the class
and this class is going to be popular
tag
or popular tags i should say
container
and then the grid class can stay there
now as far as this one we have to rename
the data attribute
to popular tags
and then we'll do the same thing
well let's remove the hyphen here
and capitalize to p
and then we can just copy this
and paste it in here
so that should work
then inside of this container that we
have here what we are going to do is
add an anchor tag with the class of
article
and then inside of it
well we can use a placeholder here and
then inside of it we can use a span that
has the class of tag name
and then here we can just say
travel
then underneath we are going to have an
image
this image is going to have the class of
article image
and the image is going to be inside of
the assets folder images folder
and then tags and then this one is going
to be the travel image
so that's going to be the basic
structure for every single card that we
are going to have inside of the popular
tags
so let's go ahead and copy this
and paste it down below
five more times
just like so
well we need six so we need one more
so now we can go ahead and just change
the text inside of it as well as the
images so the second one is going to be
food
let me actually capitalize here
so food
do the same
here and then this one is going to be
the food
tag
and i'm not sure if that's what i named
it so let's find out so yep that's going
to be the one
then the third one is going to be
technology
here we'll do the same
then we'll do the same for the fourth
one
which is
health
then the fifth one is going to be nature
and finally we have bitness
so all of our images are now there
let's go ahead and go inside of the css
file now so that we can make this look
better
so in here what we will do is target the
popular tags container
we are going to apply a gap for
separation
then we are going to target the popular
tax container article
and what we are going to do here is give
this a min height as well
and this one is going to be sm
then i'm going to select
the tag name
and this will have a position of
absolute
then i'm going to also add a c index
here of 10 so that now the item is going
to show up on top of the image
and then i'm also going to place it in
the middle by using top 50
left fifty percent and then transform
translate
negative fifty percent
and then negative fifty percent
now i'm going to add a background color
which is going to be the transparent
dark color
and that's pretty much
all we need for that actually one more
thing that we do need here is a padding
so the padding is going to be one rim
top and bottom
two ram left and right
then what we are going to do is select
the popular tags container the article
inside of it and we are going to add a
hover effect so that when we hover over
it the tag name is going to change
colors
so popular
tags container
article
unhover
and then
tag name
so here we want to change the color to
the light color
and if we test that out you can see that
it works
next i want to add a hover effect to the
image so again
i'm going to copy this
paste it down below
and now i'm going to change this to be
the article image
and
should be article image
just like so
and then what i do want to change here
is the transform scale
and what i want to do is scale it by
1.05
so if we go ahead and hover over it now
you can see that it grows but there's an
issue here because it's overflowing
so we have to go back to this article
right here
and give it an overflow
of hidden
now if we go ahead and take a look at
the hover effect notice how much nicer
it looks
the next section is going to be the
newsletter section and this one is going
to be the easiest one since we will be
reusing a lot of the styles that we
already had for this search form
so let's begin by using the section
element with the class of newsletter as
well as a class of section
in here we will have a div that has the
class of container
and then dh2 with the class of title as
well as section
title
this will be newsletter
and let's also add
the data name
so we can just go ahead and copy this
and paste it in here
scroll down and now the section title is
showing up
so underneath of here we are going to
use the div that has the classiform
container enter
so form
container
inner
and then in here we are going to have an
h6
that has the class of title
as well as the class of newsletter
title
and then we can just say subscribe
to newsflash
then underneath we are going to have a p
tag that has the class of newsletter
description
and then we can just generate some dummy
text
let's make this a lot smaller
like so
and then we are going to have the form
itself
then we can just repeat what we had
before
so input
that has the class of
warm input
type of text and then for the
placeholder we can just use
subscribe
or let me just check if that's what i
had before
and
actually we had enter your email
so that's what we are going to do
enter
your email address
then we had the
button so that's going to be a button
that has the class of btn
and form
btn
type
will be of submit
and then we can just use an icon inside
of here
ri
mail
and then
send
line
just like so and again notice how we
already have the styles because we are
just reusing this from the previous form
and that's going to be it for this one
let me just create some additional
spacing here for separation
just so that the text is more readable
so let's go ahead and go inside of the
css so that we can style the title as
well as the text that we have here
and let's find the comment
and we are going to start by selecting
the newsletter
and i'm going to give it a padding top
actually not a padding top but padding
bottom
of 6 ram
then i'm going to select the newsletter
title
and this is going to have the font size
which is going to be lg
then i'm going to select the newsletter
description
and this will have a margin bottom
should be margin bottom
and this is going to be 3ram
and that's going to give us some more
separation between the text and the form
and that's pretty much it for this
section
the next section is going to be the
footer
so let's go back inside of the
index.html and let's begin
so we're almost there the only thing we
have left after this obviously is going
to be the css for the footer
and then the
blog post page as well as the css for
that page
and then we can finally move on to the
media queries so that we can make
the website responsive and finish the
project
so for the footer we are going to be
using the footer element
and we will apply the class of footer
as well as the class of section
then we will have a div that has the
class of footer container
as well as the class of container
and then we will have the class of d
grid
since this one is going to be a grid
container as well
then in here i'm going to have a div
this div is going to have the class of
company data
and then here we are going to
have all the data that you see here so
it's going to have the logo
a brief description
social media icons and then the
copyright notice
so to begin with that what we have to do
is just add in the logo
since we already have the logo here
let's just go ahead and scroll all the
way back to the top
and let's just grab this
then we can go
back inside of the footer
and paste it down here
then we are going to have a b tag that
has the class of company
description
and here again we can just use some
dummy text so let me just copy what i
have here
paste it in here
and then we can just go ahead and add in
the social media icons
so for that i'm going to have a ul that
has the class of list
and the class of social
media
then we will have an li that has the
class of list item
then we will have the anchor tag
list link
and finally inside of here we will have
each individual icon
so the first one is going to be for
instagram or i
instagram
and then line
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that now we see the icon
then we can just go ahead and copy this
down below
as many times
as you need
and now all we have to do is just change
the classes so for this one we can do
facebook
circle
line
then the
third one is going to be for twitter
and the last one is going to be for
pinterest
and now we have all the icons that we
need
so the last thing that we need here is
going to be the copyright notice
so this is just going to be a span that
has the class of copyright
and notice
and then we just use ampersand copy
2021
well we're actually in 2022 by now
and this should be a semicolon
and now that's just going to generate
the little copyright icon
so next we can just do newsflash
all right reserved
then the next thing that i want to do
is have another div and this is going to
be for
the content that we have here
so we want to group them together
and we're watching so outside of this
company data div
we want to have another div
and this div is not going to have any
classes
this is only for the purpose since we
are using grid here
on the main container we want to group
them together
just so that the titles here are also
together and not like
all spread around this container
so
what we have to do next is inside of
here we will have an h6 that is going to
have the class of title
as well as the class of footer
title
and then we can just have any name
depending on whatever photo items you
want
this one i called it categories
then underneath
i have another ul
that has the class of list
as well as the class of footer
list
and the second class of footer list is
just so that i can
override some of the styles
that the list has without having to
impact every single list
then again li list item
anchor tag
list
link
and then for the text we can do anything
in this example i'll just do the same
text everywhere else so i'm actually
just going to do
sample item
and now we can just copy it down below
as many times as we need
so in this situation i'm doing about
let me just do six
so now that we have the base for every
single item it's as simple as just
copying this one
and now i'm going to paste it underneath
two more times
so we have a total of three of them
just like so
and just to make it a little different
let me change the titles
so here i can say company
and then for
this one
what did i actually call it i can't
remember so here we have company
useful links
and that's going to be it for the markup
for the footer let's go ahead back
inside of the main.css
and let's style this up
so the first thing that i'm going to do
is select the footer
the footer is going to have a background
color
which is going to be the secondary
background color
then the footer container
and this will have a gap
then as far as the company data
we want to do a display of flex here
then
a flex direction of column to bring in
back down
flex direction
and
the next thing that i want to do in here
is change
the order by moving this data all the
way to the
bottom
so we can do order
of one
and that's going to move it down and i
know where you're thinking
why is it going to the second place if
the order is set to one and not just
stay up here
well that's because it starts with zero
and not one so technically number zero
would be the first one
then i'm going to select the company
description
and this will have a margin block
and i'm going to do the margin sm
then the max width here that i'm going
to set is going to be 75
just to limit how wide it's going to
stretch to
the next thing that i'm going to select
is going to be the social media
and here i'm going to set a margin
bottom
and this one is going to be the margin
md
now i'm going to select the copyright
notice
and i'm going to turn the opacity down
just to make it slightly lighter
now i'm going to select the folder list
now i'm going to select the footer list
and this will have a flex direction of
column
then i'm going to align items
to flex start
just like so
and then i'm going to select the folder
title
and what i'm going to do here is change
the font size
to
maybe i'll do font size md
text transform
transform
is going to be of uppercase
and then a margin bottom for additional
separation of margin sm
and that's looking pretty good well we
have an issue here so
that's going to be within the markup
let's go ahead and find it so useful
links it must have happened when i
change the text here
so that was the issue right there now
everything looks pretty good
so the next thing that i'm going to do
now is style the scroll bar
let me make a comment here scroll bar
styles
and what i want to do here is select the
scroll bar
so for that we actually have to use a
prefix webkit
scroll bar
and i'm going to change the width to one
ram
then what i'll do
is select the scroll bar track
and in here i'm going to change the
background color to f1
f1 f1
then i'm going to select the scroll bar
thumb
and this will have a different color so
background
and then three
f4
two five
four
then i'm going to select the scroll bar
thumb when it's being hovered
and add another color to it
so in fact we can just copy this
paste it down here
and now we can just add hover to it
and the color that i'm going to add here
is going to be slightly darker
so 2
e
3 0
and then
3
b
and as you can see if we hover over it
here
it shows up
maybe i could do
1.5 to make it slightly bigger
that's actually fine so i guess we can
just keep that
although in the demo it's smaller
well it's not a big deal so i guess we
can just keep it at one
and now we can go ahead and work on the
blog post page so let's open up the
sidebar ctrl b
and then open up the post.html so as you
can see here i'm already including the
header markup
as well as the search
and then the footer because this is
content that every single page is going
to have in common so we have to include
it
so if we navigate to the page
here you see the header as well as the
footer and then everything else still
works the same
so the focus here is going to be in
between this blog post comment and the
footer comment
this is where all the blog post markup
is going to go
so let me close this
and everything else that we don't need
and what we are going to do here
is start by having a section
that has the class of blog post
as well as a class of section
header offset
and if you remember this class is going
to move a particular section that is
next to the header down enough so that
it's not sitting underneath
so then what we are going to do here is
have another div and this div is going
to have the class
of blog post
container
and let's also apply the container class
and underneath of this we are going to
have another div and this div is going
to have the class of blog post data
so this is going to be the container for
all the data that we have right here
and then we can just repeat what we have
used before which is the
well before that let's add in an h3
that has the class of title as well as
the class of blog post
title
and then we can just repeat the title
here
and under here
what we are going to do
is say that we want a div and this div
is going to have the class of article
data
and then we will have three spans
as we did before
the middle one is going to have the
class
of spacer
i can't even remember what i called this
so let me just quickly
double check
so we had
let's quickly find it and one of the
articles here is oracle data
so article data spacer that's what we
called it
so let's use it here
and then here we can just add
and then this is going to be the
estimated retime
so that's going to be the base for that
so still within this
blog post data
we need to also have an image
and this image is going to be underneath
of this article data div
so for that
we will use an image and this image
is going to be found inside of the
assets folder
images folder
and then
featured featured one
so let's see how that looks looks good
so far
and
let me just make sure that i have this
one correct as well
so let's go all the way back to the top
header
so section header offset
and there we go now it's under it
so let me close the sidebar now
and uh we can continue so this one is
going to be for this one let's go
underneath
and
in here we want to have an inner
container because we want to
limit this even further when we're on
larger screens
so we will have a class of container
here applied to a div
and inside of this div we are going to
have a p tag
some dummy text
and then we can just repeat that
underneath let me just add some
separation here so that
the text is more readable
then we are going to have a block quote
which is going to be this
and for this we can just use
the block quote element
and let's apply a class of quote
and here i'm going to have a p tag
and then i'm going to have a span
this band is going to have an icon
inside of it which is going to be for
the quotation marks
so this icon is going to have a class of
array
double
quotes
l
so let's take a look at that and now we
see the icon showing up here
then after this span closing tag we are
going to add some additional text
and in fact we don't really want a lot
so what i'll do is just copy a portion
of this
let's say about here and then paste it
in here
and then we can just repeat the same
thing
with the span
so that we get the closing
quotation mark
so the only difference here is that we
have to change the icon here so that
it's facing the left
and this one we can just change it from
l
to r
or right
just like
so and then we just repeat the same
p tag that we have here
underneath
and now we can go ahead and add the card
itself
so this card
is going to be inside another div
it's going to be inside an order div
it's going to be inside
an outer div
and we are going to call this one author
and then we will make it a grid
container
and here we are going to have a div and
this div is going to have the class of
author image box
inside of it we will have an image
and this image is going to have the
class of
article
image
and we can find it inside of the assets
folder
images folder
and then it's going to be the author.jpg
so let's scroll down here now we can see
the image
and then we can go underneath of this
author image box div
and now we will have another div that
has the class
author
about
and in here we will just have a
description of the author including the
name and so on
so it will be nh3 that has the class
of author name
then
well we can use john doe here
then we will have a p tag
this p tag is going to
have some dummy text as well
let me make this smaller
and under the p tag we will have the
social media icons
and in fact something that we can do is
just borrow it from
here
since it will be
basically the same thing and then we can
just paste it here
let me see how many did we have we had
instagram facebook and twitter
so i guess we don't need the last one
and um yeah that's pretty much
everything that we need for the markup
as far as the blog post
so now let's go inside of the css file
and style up this page
so we will begin here by selecting the
blog post
and i'm going to give this a padding
bottom
of 5 ram
then i'm going to select the blog post
data
and i'm going to give this a display
of flex
then flex direction
column
and then i want to align items to the
center
i'm going to do the same thing for the
text online
and then i'm going to apply a padding
block
of 2.5 ram
then i'm going to select the blog post
title
and here what i want to do is add
responsive typography
so i'm going to say font size and then
i'm going to use lamp
so here what i'll do is specify a
minimum font size
then in here i want to set a font size
that is going to adjust based on the
viewport width
so in this situation i'm going to do 5
bw
and then this right here is going to be
the maximum
size
so for example if we go ahead and test
that out
and let me just make sure that i grab
the right handle
and even then i still wasn't able to
grab it notice how the size of the font
is growing and once it gets to that six
rem it just stops growing all together
so that's a way that you can set
responsive typography
underneath what i'm going to do is
select the blog post data
and then i'm selecting the article data
that's inside of it
and this will have a margin bottom
margin bottom
which is going to be 2.5 ram
then i'm going to select the blog post
data image
the width here is going to be a hundred
percent
the height is going to be the
item min height sm
and then
object fit
cover
we also want to set an object position
here
and it will be center
10
just like so
then i'm going to select the blog post
container
and then
the container that is inside of it
so this would be
this container that we have here inside
of this blog post container
and here i'm going to set a max width
this max width is going to be
90 rem so that's as large as it will get
then i'm going to get rid of the padding
that we have by default on the container
class and then this will be a display of
flex
display
flex
and then here we want to change the flex
direction back to column
and then we are going to apply a gap
which is going to be the gap variable
that we have
and that's just going to
basically add some spacing between all
of our items as you can see here
so the next thing that i want to do is
style up the quote
the quote is going to have a background
color
which is going to be the secondary
background color
and it will also
it will also have a padding
all around of 2.5 ram
then underneath i'm going to select the
quote paragraph
and i'm going to set the font style
to italic
then i'm going to select the quote span
and this will have a font size of 5 ram
so that's going to make the quotes here
larger
and i should be selecting the span i
just like so
although that's actually pretty large
let me make it
smaller let's do something like half
it's actually too small so let's do 3.5
and that's better
so now i'm going to select the author
element
or the element with the class of author
and i'm going to apply a margin top
of 5 ram
and then a gap
which is going to be
the gap variable that we already have
then we can go ahead and add a
background color which is going to be
the secondary background color
let me just scroll down so that we can
see what's going on but we can't see
much of it right now because of the
large image
so let's sort that out
author image box
and all we have to do here is just give
it a position
of relative
so if we scroll up
now we still can't see it
but we're going to be fixing that
shortly
now the height is going to be item in
height sm
just like so
then i'm going to select the author
about
and this will have a padding all around
of 1.5 ram
then
display will be a flex
and flex direction here
will be column
and then in here i'm going to apply a
gap of one rem for separation between
the content that we have here
now i'll select the author name
and this will have a color
which is going to be the light color
followed by font weight
of 400.
the next thing that i'm going to select
is going to be the author
paragraph
and this will have a max width
of 50 ram
and a margin bottom
of one run
finally we are going to select the
author social media
so author
about
and then the social media
element that is inside of it
just scroll down a little bit more
and here what we want to do is set the
margin top
to auto
and what this will do is that when we
have a lot more room towards the bottom
this social media container is going to
move as far as i can to the bottom
without touching this
and then i'm also going to get rid of
the margin bottom that we have here by
setting it to zero
so now comes the fun part this is where
we make the website responsive so under
the media queries
we will do
a media
and then screen
and we do min width
followed by the breakpoint that i'm
going to be using which is going to be
700 pixels
then here what i want to do is target
the trending news box
and let's go back to the main page so
that we can see what's going on
i'm also going to go ahead and make this
smaller back to a hundred percent just
so that it's easier to show
the breakpoints
so this is going to be for the trending
use box which is this one right here
and what i'm going to do here is change
the flex direction to row
then what i'll do here is add align
items to the center
and we still can't see it because we're
not at the 700 breakpoint
but there we are
then i'm going to select the trending
use image box
and this will get a width
of 50
so now things are going to fit better
now i'm going to select the trending
news data
and the margin here is going to be set
to auto
so now this will move towards the middle
text align
here will be center as well
then i'm going to select the newsletter
description
so let me scroll back down to the
newsletter
right
here
so
letter description
and the max width here is going to be
set to 40 ram
and then for the form
container
enter
i'm going to set and align items here of
center
just like so
then for the popular tags while the
popular tags actually come before this
so let me just move up
with the popular tags container
as well as the footer container
what i'll do here is just change the
layout so now we're going to have sets
side by side
so what i'll do is say grid template
columns i want to use the repeat
function
and then i want to specify how many
times i want this repeated so i want it
two times
and it's going to be one fraction each
so now you can see that they're both
side by side
then for the
company data
which is this right here i'm going to
change the order
back to the first one so zero and that's
going to place it over here instead
then if we go back to the
blog post page
here i'm going to select
the
author
and i'm going to set a grid template
columns here
so the first side is going to be 25 ram
that's the side for the image
and then the other one is going to be
one fraction so as much space as it can
and that's going to give us a better
layout and notice how the margin auto
down here is coming into play by pushing
it all the way to the to the bottom
so let's now work on the second
breakpoint
let me just grab this
paste it underneath
and then i can just go ahead and close
this
so the second breakpoint is going to be
for tablets
so i'm going to change this one to 768.
and when it comes to choosing your
breakpoints all you have to do is just
go on the responsive view
so let me just make this bigger
so for example you go on the responsive
view
and then all you have to do is just use
the handle to stretch the viewport here
and just kind of figure out where the
layout breaks and then that's going to
allow you to choose a breakpoint where
you can correct that issue that you're
currently having with the layout
breaking
so let me quickly close that and let's
go back
to working on the second breakpoint
so let's go back to the main page and
this is going to be for the featured
content
so featured
content
and
here i want to set a grid template
columns
so i want this to be repeated
four times
and then one fraction each
then what i want to do is specify some
grid template rows
and
the template rows
here i want to say that the first one is
going to be 5 ram
so that's going to be for this
banner then the other ones i'm going to
repeat them four times
one fraction each as well
don't worry still looks messed up but
it's going to make a lot more sense
soon so let me just make this bigger
so that i have a chance to open up the
responsive view here and then if we go
here and take a look at the grid
and what we can do now
is
basically position the elements where we
want them to
go
so as far as the headline banner
what i'll do here
is set a grid column
and then i want to say start
at one so that's going to be the first
line and stretch all the way across here
to negative six
so for this we can just do negative one
and now notice how the layout is
correcting itself and this let me just
remove this so that's more visible
now the banner is stretching all across
then what i'll do
is stretch it further down so i'm going
to set a grid row
and then i'm going to tell it start
actually not a grid row i'm going to be
doing that on the other ones not this
one what i want to set here
is a font size
which is going to be the font size
sm
so now i'm going to select the featured
article
and this one is going to have a grid
column
it will start at 3
and then stretch
all the way to the end
just like so
then for the grid row
i'm going to say start a line number two
and finish a number four
then i'm going to select the featured
article number one this is me selecting
them individually
should be number one
and then here i'm going to set a grid
column
telling it to start at one and finish
at three
like so
let me copy this
paste it underneath
and now i'm going to change this to
number two
and for number two well actually for
number two we don't need it because
number two it's already sharing the
styles that we just applied to every
single featured article here
however the one that we do need is
number three
and this one is going to start at number
one and then stretch all across to the
end
just like we did here with the banner
then what i want to do
is tell it to
start
on the grid row
at 4
and finish at six
just like so
and notice how we went from a boring
layout to this really nice looking
layout that we have now
so we can close this for now
and the next thing that i want to do
is target the older post
so here older post
and then the article inside of it
and here i can say grid template columns
the first one 25 ram and the rest one fr
so now we get a similar card as to what
we had for the blog post
for the author card that we have
then underneath i'm going to select the
older post article image wrapper
and the height is going to be set to
auto
the next thing that i'm going to do is
target the blog post
data image
and here what i want to do is change the
height
from
sm
to md
just like so
and let's not forget to close this so
that it works and now you see that it
does
and that's going to be it for this
breakpoint now we move on to the third
breakpoint
so again as we did before
let me just copy this one so without we
don't have to type it again
paste it down here
and all we have to do now is change
the breakpoint so here we do
10 24. and in here we are going to reset
the menu
so i'm going to change the position to
initial
then
the width
to initial as well
padding
initial
background color transparent
and then the opacity
initial
and we will do the same thing for the
transform
so the next thing that i'm going to do
is target the list that is a direct
child of the
menu
element
and here the flex direction
will be changed back to row
so now we have to hide these two buttons
for the sign in and sign up since we are
in the
desktop screens now
and to do that all we have to do is say
green lg hidden
and now we can say display
none and it's gone
so now what we have to do is show the
other two buttons that we had on the
side so if i make this
smaller here
these two buttons
to do that we just select the opposite
class that we had for this which was
screen
sm hidden
and then we do a display of block
like so
so the only thing we have to do here is
style this button to make it look like
the fancy button that we had before
and to do so first i'm going to select
the sign up
btn
and this will now get a padding all
around
of point
or
ramp
and now the background is going to show
up
we still have to animate this button on
hover
so for that we are going to be creating
a keyframe animation so we will do add
keyframe
and then
the name
here i'm going to call this animate
border
and then we usually have a starting
position and then an ending position
so you can say
from like zero
then anything in between to a hundred
percent or any amount to be honest
but here i'm just going to do
two which is basically going to be the
ending position
because you can have from
basically saying start here and then 2
and here
so 2 what i want to animate here is the
transform
translate
x
then negative 50 percent and that's
pretty much it
so all we have to do now is just add
this animation on hover
so here i'm going to select the btn that
has the class of fancy border
and
i'm going to say
that on hover
i want to target w4 sudo element
and then here i set the animation
property
then followed by the
name of the keyframe animation which is
going to be
animate border
i'll say
over
0.75 seconds the animation is going to
be linear
and it will be infinite
so if we go ahead and test that out
well it's not working
let's see if we can find the issue so
here selecting the btn that has to class
a fancy border on hover
and then we target the before
pseudoelement and apply the animation
so let me just go ahead and try this by
itself
oh by the way the reason why i do the
btn is because i want the effect to only
well it's working there
but yeah i was saying that i only want
this effect to apply to this button and
not this right here because if you
remember correctly this also has the
fancy border class
so that tells me that the issue comes
from the btn
so let's go back inside of the
[Music]
index.html
make this larger
and if we scroll down here find the
button
well here we can see that i have btt as
opposed to btn
so i'm assuming i have the same mistake
here as well
and yes we do so let's correct that
and now we can just go ahead and close
all of this since we are only going to
be working within the css file now
so let's make this
smaller
and now if we go ahead and test that out
this doesn't work which is exactly what
we want
but this should not work and it does
so moving on the next thing that i want
to select is the featured articles
container
and here what i want to do is apply
a grid template columns
one fraction
and then 40 ram which is going to be for
this side so now they're going to be
side by side here
then what i want to do is select the
trending news image box
and this is going to get a width of 10
rem
a height of 10 ram as well
and then what i want to do is select the
popular tags container
right here
and
what i want to do in there
is set another grid template columns
repeat
three times
one fraction each
then for the next one this is going to
be for the footer container so i guess
we can just copy this paste it down
below
in this one we can just change the name
to
butter
container
and this one is going to be repeated
five times instead
just like so now we have to correct this
because obviously it doesn't look right
at all
so since we are now spanning five what i
can do here
is
target the company data
company data
and what i can say is that the grid
column
i want it to span
by two because we have four items
so let me just comment that out now
so let me just comment that out for now
so here we have four items but now we
are basically saying that we want this
repeated five times
so we don't have enough room to fill
every single one so it just stays like
that
so what we do here is just span this one
by two so now it makes up for the space
that we have here empty
and it just looks a lot better as you
can see
now i'm going to select the company
description
and this is going to have a max width
of 85 percent
so it's just going to stretch out a
little bit more
now for the copyright notice
here i'm going to give this a margin top
of auto and it's going to push the text
all the way to the bottom
finally i'm going to select the blog
post data image so let's go back to the
blog post page
so blog post data
and then the image inside of it
and the height here is going to be 40
ram
like so
now we can go ahead and move over to the
next breakpoint
and this breakpoint is going to be at
1200
pixels
and what i want to do here is very
simple i just want to
modify the older pose grid wrapper
which is this one right here
since now we have plenty of room
what we can do is say older posts
grid wrapper
grid template columns and then i want to
repeat this
two times one fraction each
so if we go ahead and make this bigger
you'll see that now we get the layout
that we want
then what i want to do is add another
breakpoint and this one
is going to be
at
15
1500 pixels
and then i only want to focus here on
the
featured article and
what i'm going to do here so featured
article
is set the grid
template
column
to start three and stretch all the way
to the end obviously we're not going to
see any changes there because we are not
in a large enough view
but if we made it bigger now you can see
it well you can't see it because it's
being messed up we have to correct it
and to do so what we have to do is
select featured article
number one
and then i can say here grid column
one
and a three
and then for the grid row
we can say start a two
and as you can see here now this portion
is a lot larger and stretches all the
way towards the bottom
now let's just make sure that everything
still works
so looks good so far
this as well change the theme
local storage still works
and while there's an issue here as you
can see
it's not changing to the appropriate
color because if we went back to the
original project
this should be blending in with the same
color as the navigation for the header
and
everything else we have here
so
let's go ahead
and go back inside of visual studio code
and since this is related to the live
theme all we have to do is just come
here
and
well this is the issue right here this
should be the light color instead
so light and this one should be dark
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that
and it works but we still don't have the
right color
as you can see
and um that's because this one should be
the same as this one
so now it should work
well it's still broken because once it
switches to the black color the title
should be white
so let's take a look at the hover effect
for the article
which should be somewhere around here
oh that's because i did not add it in so
article
on hover
we want to target the article title
and what we want to do here
is just change the color
to be the transparent
was it the light color no actually it
was the hover
light color
so let's go ahead and test it out and as
you can see now everything
works perfectly and everything else
still looks good
so let's check out the responsiveness
so right here this is the mobile view
the navigation still works
this as
well
if you scroll down everything still
looks good let me check out the swiper
and let's now
adjust the viewport width and everything
still
scaling properly
and um yeah it looks like we are done
so if you guys enjoyed this video
tutorial make sure to show me some love
and if you have any questions leave them
in the comments down below and hopefully
i can clarify any doubts that you might
have
feel free to also check out the
completed files just in case you run
into issues as i mentioned at the
beginning
so that you can fix them a lot faster
and not have to wait for a response
other than that i'll catch you guys in
the next one